the french president looked relaxed as
he voted in the coastal resort of le
tuke but emmanuel macron faces a
challenging week after the first round
of france's parliamentary elections his
centrist alliance is on track to win
most seats but not necessarily the
majority he needs to push ahead with his
reform agenda
we are the only political movement in a
position to win a majority in the
national assembly we have one week
before us to rally our forces one week
to persuade one week to win a strong and
clear majority only such a strong and
clear majority will enable us to respond
to the urgent issues which affect the
daily lives of french people
a new left-wing block that includes
greens communists and socialists created
by far-left leader jealous
has emerged as the main rival to
macron's party it's attracted voters
concerned over the cost of living and
climate change
i call on our people viewing this result
and this opportunity for our personal
lives and for the nation i call on
people to go out and reject once and for
all the funeral project of macron
the far right and conservative parties
trailed the centrists and the left in an
election that's largely failed to
capture voters imagination turnout was
at an historic low with less than half
of those eligible casting their ballot
this vote comes less than two months
after the presidential campaign so
there's definitely a sense of election
fatigue it's also the case though that a
growing number of people in france feel
fed up of politics and politicians and
increasingly disengaged from the
political process
with a tight race ahead the parties will
step up their campaigns in a critical
test for the president the big lesson of
this first round for emmanuel macron is
that he's not certain to have an
absolute majority in parliament and that
will make his life more difficult if he
hasn't got one so he he's tried to
hammer this message in the last few days
before the first round and he will be
trying to push that message for the
second round give me a majority
in one week voters will return to the
polls for the second round of the
election and will determine how france
is governed for the next five years
whether there will be a swing to the
left or more of the same natasha butler
al jazeera paris